[ Silence ]
He's just good doctor.
He said a long ass fight.
[ Laughter ]
[ Silence ]
I've been training with Whale because after a couple of ass battles he's realized he could increase his speed and stuff like that.
His exterities and he knows Will is pretty good at that so he's just been training with Will to frame that up.
And then during -- you said they're like trying to stay away from the spiders nest during the daytime.
Then when they're doing that I would have been going around just talking to each member of the crew just to like get a feel of where they're at right now and what they were looking for a long term ghost and stuff like that.
[ Silence ]
There are more people in the island that were captured beside us. If we managed to get out more people probably would as well and who know if they got captured again.
So finding everyone that got captured.
Well, if there are any sins as well they don't deserve to be locked up and treated as such. And after you do that.
Yeah. A little time of the elements, stuff happens. That's good. I wish our vote didn't disappear so we could have got one step closer with the journal that we had.
But when we find out we will get our first clue. Well, she was always tough on a few more days with probably no magic. I'm sure she's okay to read her shoes.
I hope so at least. I do too.
I'll see you soon. What about you? What about you? What are you planning to do?
You guys talking to me? No.
I wish I knew. I...
I hope you guys have been haunted for a long time. It's always been a goal of mine to find a place to settle down and we're not hunted.
Bring our reputation back to what it once was so people no longer treat us.
That's the way they currently do. That is a long and perilous road. It may not be feasible.
Well, I'll stand beside you. Whatever shows you make.
Thank you.
I'll go find Roman next.
I'm trying to make a fantastic meal. I'm talking like...
I'm talking to our salt and curing meats. I'm smoking them. You know what I'm saying?
Dehydrate in some shit.
I'm telling you, I'm getting to the point where I'm in my three places at once, splitting the mine up.
I'm diced and churred up.
I'm fucking shit up in this kitchen. You know what I'm saying?
I got a kitchen that actually has some shit.
Yeah.
He can't, but I ain't going to be talking. I'm going to literally be running around like he going to be seeing shit flying through the air like.
I'm going to tell you, I have teeth like come back when I'm ready.
If he says that then I would have left, let him do his thing.
Well, the first day was definitely recovering from all the trauma I had from all this time.
The ship went away, some people died. We saved it people, but he lost his tongue.
The people we were, uh, venturing with killed another guy and they got killed. And then I died a few times almost and then mouth was almost dry died to like an ice cream machine or something to some kind of claw.
So basically that's the end and then the guy that was trying to kill us also happened to have a traumatic backstory. So yeah.
He has been through a lot and he had needs at least a day to like recover. So the first day, but was what immediately like went to some kind of storeroom or something and like just stayed there trying to get a hold of himself and he to like get a hold of himself.
When back to his element, like researching stuff to like forget about all the stuff that happened, but he like kept thinking of how the actual combat worked and how it's not like the experiments that he normally did like if you like break a machine, yeah, you can just do it back.
And like combat, there's no do over and if the next time he got so close to dying, there might not be another time to come back to it. So, uh, he likes all of these thoughts that like running on his head and after he like come down a bit.
He tried to focus on increasing his survivability. So he kind of try to focus on learning on how the other guys who are actually experiencing combat like Roma mouth and that is how they actually fought and dead stuff.
He kind of tried to do some research on their fighting styles and whatnot to improve his skillset and try to like increase his survivability.
Also, while doing that like all these all these three days, he was probably almost fully isolated on his like the story that he is at, but like coming out to only eat and going back in again, but he kind of realized that
almost everyone around him like had devil fruits like and the thing that he's supposed to be doing is researching devil fruits and he all this time he hasn't even noticed so he's trying to think of some ways to get to like talk to other guys about how they got their devil fruits and
how they how they those work, but he still it doesn't know how to do that because yeah, researching with other people is not kind of his specialty.
Yup.
you
a lot has happened.
You know, one day, one of the other three days, I've teached nots on the door, Bob, the first knock, nothing, you don't hear response.
I'll just enter.
You're all right in here.
What what what what are you doing here.
Well, I am absolutely fine. You do not need to worry about me, my good man. And then you see Bob and like you you know Bob the cyborg and he doesn't really needs to do the whole sleeping thing, but he
kind of has bags under his eyes and it kind of he hasn't taken any risk almost at all.
Why are you pushing yourself so hard?
Oh, no, I'm not pushing yourself, pushing myself correction. I am.
Oh, yeah, right. I am pushing myself.
But you don't need to worry. Okay, you don't need to worry. This is what I love doing. Okay, you haven't seen me much outside. Oh, sorry, you haven't seen me much inside a ship break. So this is usually what I normally do when I'm in a ship.
Oh, why?
I'm not dying actually. So yeah, this is basically my goal to make it do. What are you doing here?
I just want to get a feel on where you want to go.
What's your goal?
Right now, I mean, I'm on a mission, you know, like the whole check what happened to the second Fleet Camon commander and like get to fear or something. Don't you have the same mission?
What drives you to stick with the food?
Yeah, we could role play him.
Titties, Bob. Titties, Bob.
Yeah, no, no, Roman, you don't know. You do not have big enough tedious for me. Okay.
Exactly. That's what that's what thrives you.
You want to be that bird cyborg? No, you want to be that bird cyborg?
Why do you want to have those? Or do I want to get those? What's?
Get those you want to get all of them?
You have to touch all of them.
I want you master row sheet level.
I want you master row sheet perverted level.
Anyway, I don't want to go bald, okay?
I'm just saying you could be in your room instead of bags under your eyes, he could have walked in and caught you doing something else. You know what I'm saying?
Like WD40.
Exactly. Greasing up the joints, you know what I'm saying?
And what drives you was titties.
I'm going to read everything I said of my character. That's what I'm going with.
You should be working.
Oh, it would be fucking hilarious if Bob was like perverted like the whole time.
What's the perverted cyborg? What's he going to do?
That's what he's going to get attachments. You know what I'm saying?
When she was tied up, he like.
He like being.
Fixed their size, right?
Using attachments.
So I would probably be very good at that.
Wasn't this about to be about our character development? What are you doing?
This is part of character development.
Do you feel like you're not developing?
I'm developing something.
You should be developing that armor.
Well, look, I'm not exactly very, you know, you have seen me do stuff with machines,
but that's not what my expert is lies it.
It's mainly at like, you know, the other world, the magical stuff that you guys excel at.
But I try to just replicate all of those with my like measly machines, but I am basically a scholar, not a mechanic, you know.
But I tried.
I am trying.
I'm trying to like learn how the armor works and trying to integrate into integrate those in my body, but it's really hard for me to do that.
What's not hard for me to do is like research about devil fruits and on that note, you did say you had a devil fruit, right?
I never said such a thing.
So all those fiery stuff that you did to blow the whole thing up, that's just what my fires.
You like little bit of fire when blowing the, blowing the cave up, right?
Sorry, I'm just going to ask, do you not have a devil fruit?
No, well, he has a puzzle box that we think contains on.
What?
Wait, what the hell are you guys talking about?
No, no, okay, we went to yeah, let's get Roman this as well.
Me and Baptist, we're going to get out to get some food and we're just going to start talking right in front of a conversation.
And then he has to come out.
Are you there?
I'm so confused what's going on right now.
I'm asking you about all fruit and I'm not answering.
Oh, well, I'm going to tell you right now, I have no fucking idea.
So okay, I need to find out which one of you has devil fruit.
I'm pretty sure veil has it because he said it.
Do you have it from?
What?
A devil fruit?
I have an ability.
I can do some shit, but I don't have one.
Wait, nobody has one.
How do you guys do all those abilities?
Where did those come from?
Yeah, oh, that makes sense.
So you ate a devil fruit.
Okay, this is a new information.
So basically you need to eat the devil fruit to get the power.
No idea, that's what I did.
I was trying to see if it tastes good.
I was going to mix it in some shit.
So I took a little beat.
Next thing you know, I'm something happens when I get too angry.
Is it like one time thing?
What is the devil fruit?
Is it inside of your body?
I have no idea.
You think I look at my shit after I shit?
I'm going to get a shit after I shit.
Tell me you never...
Are you guys telling me you never wondered what happened to you devil fruit
after it went inside your body?
Not!
Why are you making that?
It was food.
I know what happens.
You chew it up, you digest, you poop it out.
But I ain't going to turn around and look.
Yeah, but you need to think scientifically.
That is scientifically.
What else do you do with food?
You eat it, you digest it, you shit it out.
You know anything else other than that?
Maybe occasionally it goes the other way where you throw it up because you know other...
other stuff.
What do you try to get at?
You think it somehow still in me?
I mean you still have the power?
It's something that gave me.
I have no idea.
You want to come get inside me Bob?
What do you have been playing?
Are you trying to save more shit?
Do you want to find out?
No.
You think I'm just going to let you cut me open?
No, I'd love to help you.
I'm just saying this to help.
Hell no.
I'm telling you that right now.
That is a hell to the know.
Plus that I kind of like it.
You know, I go, I go, Hulk, you know, Hulk's mask, you know, Hulk got, you know, the shit.
Digging me back.
Well, I guess I can't do anything with you then.
Well, Baptist, did you, did you eat one as well?
Eat one.
A double fruit?
Not that I remember.
Do you know of anyone who has eaten a double fruit recently?
I don't know.
Like, uh, yesterday or like six hours, how much does it, uh, 12 hours actually?
We've been together for the past 12 hours.
I will never mind.
Are you sure you're okay?
Yeah, maybe don't worry.
He's gonna like do a big thigh and like go to slowly walk back.
We had interesting conversations.
Yeah, you're back.
Oh, we brought the ball to go to people.
No, that's not.
Uh, not yet.
So basically the first, the first day, I'm just gonna sit down and meditate.
Like to control bill my own energy.
I'm the second day probably all go talk to, uh, well, no, he's a pizza.
And the third day, I'm just gonna be in the sky, like trying to discharge the energy to my legs and stuff to be faster.
So I won't like discharge on the ship.
The way you say discharge is kind of creepy.
Not this.
That's definitely thunder.
The end get me to the bowl.
Except broma, because broma was busy.
So like, you know, those scenes were like, motherfucker's cakes open door smoke comes out, you know, radic answer.
That's what's happening right now.
Let's go.
This is the.
Is he okay?
Hello.
I'm gonna like throw a bit of water on his face and if it doesn't work, I'm gonna cool though, I'm gonna like get some ice water and throw it because he's like in Yeti.
So it's probably.
What do you want me to do just like, let's see if regular water works.
Does it work? No, you know what, let's go with that word or first.
You just go.
Like how much water are we talking like?
How much can I get?
I mean, you know, I'm not that strong, but how much can I get?
You just know, like, are you taking a handful or a whole fuller?
With like the cute stuff.
Yeah, that's definitely gonna wake my ass up.
Like, I'm like, what the fuck?
I'm gonna see y'all not have food.
I'm like, why aren't you all eating my food?
Why are you sleeping on the ground?
What you mean?
Look where you are right now.
I'm gonna do like one of the dad stretches.
I'm gonna do like one of the dad's favorite food.
Did I see anything unusual when I first came in there to talk to him and he was busy.
Oh my god.
Deception or persuasion, you say,
which one is my better persuasion?
Oh.
Oh, definitely.
Oh, my god.
Oh, shit.
I take it.
Also, we had circumventing script for the whole three days.
She had to do it for a week.
Oh.
I'm gonna do like one of the dad's favorite food.
Oh, shit.
That's what I tell you.
So if you're talking to both of them, you're gonna say BM like bow movement.
No, no, you can't do that.
Come Zaptos and I don't know the other one.
I don't know the other one.
He's a legendary bird.
Remember, I've traveled way.
I've traveled.
It's called the canto region.
Exactly.
Yeah.
A box.
Oh.
Since we are going to be traveling for a bit.
I think he might as well.
And we are officially accrued now.
Is that better than we figure out the rankings?
I wanted to have everyone battle.
And let that choose the rankings after captain.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I have a quarter to come.
Carve the crew.
You know, you're part of our crew.
Pritzkicks with us.
Come on now.
What's it?
What should mean piss you off you with us?
Come on now.
We're out to find your whole crew.
All of the six folks.
That's only felt.
We need to move.
You're a homie.
I died for you.
We'll draw lots.
Whoever.
Does not.
It's a buy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah.
Wait.
Bob's going to like look at.
Everyone like his head goes to one.
Then another.
Wait.
All of this is moving too fast.
What.
What do you mean battle?
What do you think it means?
I don't know.
And I want to see what you're asking me.
Because you ain't shown shit.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know what this is.
I know you're trying to lure me.
No, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I know that this is some kind of trap.
But I just don't have the.
I'm trying to fuck you up.
Or see what you can do.
He's trying to fuck you.
I know that this is some kind of a trap.
But I don't have the logic to prove it.
So.
You know what for now?
I'm going to go with it.
The only rule in this competition.
No.
Why is it always me?
Are you ready?
No.
In the fight.
Damn.
Okay.
Okay. Let's do a perception check.
Let's do a perception check.
How many windows are here?
None.
You don't know who the ship.
How many windows are can I see?
Windows?
None.
You don't know the devil's ship.
We're talking to old pirate ship.
Yup.
So, it's 25th up in the air.
Oh no.
I did.
I just know.
Oh no.
The moment I said before the role,
the moment I said before the role,
he was going to get it for to his role.
He was going to get it for to his role.
I have friends.
He is going to look around to, uh, to look for windows and
to look for windows and veille, uh,
like, trying to focus on him.
And while veille is focusing,
he slips on, like, some case, like, slips on his hand.
And pushes a button to on, like, veille's part right over there.
And a, like, uh, some, how does he do that?
He's going to get it for to his part right over there.
And a, like, uh, some, how does levitate work again?
Okay.
They just float.
Yeah.
But I need to do some flavor.
So, uh, some kind of, uh, uh, some kind of, like,
a tiny robot, uh, drone something flies away from his hand very
quickly and attach it itself to, uh,
who's a veille and then it kind of activates some kind of antigrory
and he goes very close up.
Oh, you could have done, like, little cross-terbancer things.
Yeah.
So, how high is the ceiling again?
There's no ceiling.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
No, I'm not going to kill him.
I'm not going to kill him.
And also he's going to go right above 20 feet.
So, like, if there's any mask, uh, near his roots,
I don't want to.
I'm going to kill him.
Dude, I need to survive.
Okay.
I need to survive.
He says that and then he is going to get the fuck out of there.
You got a rod.
That was too much.
I know that was too much.
How much is 30 feet?
That's enough.
Also, uh, how high is the, uh, anything that he could reach
so that he's not going to, uh, level take him that high
so that he can't reach any.
Is he within five feet?
Yep.
I'm running to my old friend Roma.
I'm shoving him right back.
I'm pushing him back.
Oh, hell, dude.
Yeah, let's get up over there.
All right.
What is that?
Just a straight check.
Right.
Just to,
uh,
oh, damn, I don't even have major armor.
What the hell?
What am I even doing?
Yep.
This is going to be a short bite.
I have a question.
It's a one thing.
We just hope that I have a question.
I don't even have major armor.
I didn't even get to do that before the fight because we're not
doing that in the shape, right?
So.
10 minutes.
I need to survive.
But I have a question.
So see entered five feet of me.
Can I use it as an attack of opportunity?
No, that looks.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll just fucking.
Is it just.
Yeah, I am.
But so like, is it a straight roll or effect?
Hey, referee.
Hey, referee, where there's the foul going on here?
Normal.
Okay.
Okay, so then let's do straight.
Damn.
Oh, shit.
No.
Wait, so wait.
No, do you think I can resist at 22?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's.
I'm a young.
Get your ass back.
Before he does that, I'm going to yell out to the Baptist.
I'm going to yell out to the Baptist.
You ran to him.
I thought there were no rules.
I thought I could run wherever I want.
Exactly.
There are no rules that no killing.
So he can push you.
Let's tell you to begin with.
No, he can't even hear the range.
I'm fucked.
Yeah, he should.
If he had any of these attacked time fucked.
No, no, there's something to grab and he could,
but I'm pretty sure I'm I put it somewhere that he can't
grab anything.
Yep.
That hits.
No, that doesn't hurt.
What the fuck?
Who's behind you?
You said you're going to die for me.
I didn't say you.
I said, said them.
How many does he have?
What the hell?
I'm dead.
Okay.
13 matches exactly.
My AC is 13.
Yep.
Damn, I'm dead.
I'm being a really dead.
Got some bro.
Yep, that's half my HP.
Yeah, I get a 40.
Another portant.
Oh, wait, no, I can't use that.
I can't use that.
I just use my reaction.
Never mind.
Oh, well.
Yep.
The fight is over guys.
Thanks for watching.
It's not over yet.
Well, one round.
One round more.
I'm trying not to.
You're hitting me.
You're trying not to.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's throwing.
So I'm going to like do my best to carefully.
But my guy Rome over there.
Because he loves me very much.
So let's see.
Oh, bro.
That's okay.
And how much.
Within range.
Let's go.
I mean, I don't know that he has that much range.
I just know that I need to run.
And then I'm going to cast major armor on myself because I haven't done did that yet.
No, no.
Can I push will fail down.
What the hell?
Yeah.
No, no, you just start floating.
Then you can then you can alter the movement.
So I push and I pulling against the objects.
Yes, but here's my thinking what does Bob what is Bob good at?
I'm not killing someone and like annoying people so that his teammates can kill them.
Bob is not the person to kill somebody or hit somebody or damage somebody.
That's not what I'm good at.
Bob, you fireball.
Yeah, sure.
Let's do fireball.
It's our way.
I think.
Yeah, here's.
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, but I.
Okay, thank you.
You did that 16.
Bob has the no damage.
Bob, do something.
We're getting that I'm not the guy to do the damage.
I'm not the guy to do the damage.
Three.
Wait, I could have had to find the map all this time.
Oh, fuck me.
If we had a bar, we could have actual background music being played.
Yeah.
Well.
Okay, I'm going to use my reaction to cast shield.
Well, that doesn't work.
That doesn't work.
No, it doesn't hit.
Second one hits.
Where is there is.
I'm going to use my reaction to cast shield.
Okay, so the first thing that I do is I can move him with my...
Okay, no, he's perfect where he is at.
Yeah, but he's perfect where he is at.
So I don't need to move him.
And I'm going to...
Yeah, I'm going to definitely attack.
Here's what I'm going to do.
Let's do this.
There's the mast over here, right, Dimm?
And so...
Perfect.
Okay, I don't want to piss this guy off.
So let's just see what he does.
And then I'm going to move over...
All right, over here.
So that...
Wait, what the hell?
Let's see if no more...
Yeah, perfect.
He's going to hide behind the mast.
Over here. Exactly.
So that I'm not in like...
So that I'm behind full cover.
Nope.
There's something wrong.
You want to hit your fight?
I run, okay?
Hey, hey, okay.
I want to stay here.
Nope.
That's moving without initiative.
Oh, shit.
Have a petty on you.
He's coming loose.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, my.
Oh, boy.
Oh, shit. Andy hits that bitch.
Wait, wait. He's not behind me.
How is he?
Is that French?
How much French does that have?
It's at Millie.
He moved him to the rock, as that's a...
Oh, damn.
Damn.
That's dope.
Why not?
Well.
Right. So let me get this straight.
I pissed off a guy by not hurting him while he's beating me up.
That's how I pissed off a guy.
I'm hurting is like that meme.
Minding your business and not bothering people.
Bothered people.
Okay.
How many, how many concentration saves you?
I need to do.
Oh, right.
I'm going to get a little bit more.
I'm gonna take two swipes. I'm like, come on now.
I'm gonna blood.
Nope. Yes. Yep.
Yeah.
Yeah, Damien.
Can I run across whatever that is?
Or do I get a run around it?
Oh, how far is that?
I was.
So then we're gonna go there.
Boom. We doing it again.
Oh shit. Fuck.
Didn't mean to do that.
Let me go here.
Let's do this again.
There's one.
I know that one will hit.
17.
17 and 11.
So same thing. I'm just gonna be like, kill it me.
Ah.
14.
No, 14 doesn't. It ties me.
19 hits.
Damn.
I'm just gonna keep.
Like same thing. I'm just gonna keep.
We just gonna keep trading back and forth.
Go to global.
Like.
This is how you make it.
This is how our relationship has been, bro.
I'm just gonna keep trading back.
Oh, that's hitting.
Oh,
I'm just gonna get again.
But this time, since you did that,
both of mine are for with advantage, right?
Yep,
Yep, we doing this.
We doing this.
Come on now.
With advantage.
First one.
Are you fucking me?
Okay.
We got a hit that was gotta hit 15, doesn't it god damn alright well I fucked up
All right
Oh, I should be doing that gatter gun thing
That's it and
Nope 13 doesn't hit
I'm gonna give her what she wants
It's the anytime
I'll be like alright, I'll give you what you want
Okay, so I could literally run up swing swing right oh I could still use frenzy
So would that get me
So would that give me three tech three attacks
Yeah, yeah, well shit. I'm just gonna frost call frost call
Then that's that's about I'm gonna run up and
I'm gonna run up and fuck a fire
God damn it we're the
What I hate that
God damn it
Damn dammit
Let's stay away from alpha
Oh
That's our action
So that's it
You trying to show you
Like the same thing she's like totally in here like
I
When we're raging
When you don't
Yeah, I guess I just go up
When you don't take or don't they damage that's I think it's
I was gonna say to veil are you sure we shouldn't give them some privacy or something
This this doesn't look like a battle
Because it turned off when I
What yeah, yeah, so I gotta pop again
That yep, yeah, yeah, yep
God damn that's hurting
What can I do shit it
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Fuck it.
I'm running up and swinging twice again, fuck it.
>> Yes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh shit.
So I just got to.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, and I create one of them.
And I create one of them.
>> Come on.
>> Fuck.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, I'm like uppercut, swipe, like.
That was the damage.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
15 hits, one doesn't.
Fuck.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
She's still holding onto the blade.
Oh.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So she's in my back right now.
And there's a boat right next to me.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Because I can't frost call like behind me, right?
Because I can try to, okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna frost call behind me.
Like try to swipe from behind.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Come on, I just got to hit.
God damn it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
14.
I'm dead.
She, she gonna get me.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, my Christ.
Yeah, yep.
Well, she's only got GGs.
GGs.
Yeah, you overkill.
I have six.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yep.
Oh, my God.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh.
Early.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I have a question for you.
That's a bonus action.
I'm just gonna have to swing and pop fucking second wind.
Yep.
Run up swing.
I'm just gonna, worth.
I'm just gonna scroll to see if I can find the fucking pain.
There we go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
19.
Let's go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, good old.
The fucking cannon, bro.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Avail, you wanna do something?
Okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Stop the robot.
No, fuck no, she's within range, right?
I'm gonna run and I'm gonna shove her hands up in the air.
Oh, catch.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Wait, wait, this is the easiest way.
Goddammit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[LAUGH]
We didn't even need the music, this was scary.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[LAUGH]
You accept the win like that, Roma?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm still standing so I don't know.
Like, I thought she had me, but like, I tried.
But I, like, I don't know.
Because I know she would have hit me with it, I would have been dead.
So I don't know.
I don't know, it's on you, Cap.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Bro, what do you want, what are you doing?
No, they're ain't no coin flip, this is a real hard decision.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, but she didn't kill.
But Roma also told me not to stop it.
Yes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The winner of this doubt is.
>> Cerebral.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
What the fuck?
Dude, does nobody even care about the rules?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The rules were not broken.
Also, Roma, I guess if I bought now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah.
No.
Oh.
Yeah, you said Cerebral.
Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, you ready for this?
You ready for this?
Haha, I told you Bob, I worry about that ass.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm going to kill.
Wait, it's supposed to be another role of the virus.
Because mouth is beneath you.
I'm fine taking it.
Oh, there's a pass.
So if they want to fight yourself.
Yeah.
Malfiss, mouth is a whale and circle all have to roll.
Yeah, whatever, whatever, yeah, whatever gets the highest gets the buy.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Or, or if Malfiss walks away through this entire tournament without having to fight till the end,
I will be so bad.
Who got the fight, Cerebral?
Who got the fight?
Bill, Bill, get some candy.
You fight, circle.
Don't let it rest.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
The hell?
Ah, fuck it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I mean, if it is a fight to determine, I think they should be at their top games.
Oh, he said long rest.
Is what he said.
Yeah, I mean, we'll be fed like half down and then hey, here not a deck.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
She was about to fuck you me.
[laughs]
She was about to wax my at once.
I saw that.
Can't it?
I knew exactly what was going to happen.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
By the way, does the cannon actually does any kind of real in-game bad stuff?
Or just not the one?
Yeah, then.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, wait.
She has that cannon in her hand.
Bro, why the fuck are we fighting her?
Okay, okay, in that case, she's not going to hit me because I have to use my stuff.
I'm not going to hit her.
Okay, also DM just in case she fails the wisdom saving throw.
I will ready or I don't know what the mechanics here, but I already supery bars just in case she does the cannon thing.
I mean, she probably won't because because no, no, no, no, no, that's just for the end of the I know that she's probably not going to do that because.
She loves us and doesn't want to lose our character, but just in case I don't want to lose mouth.
I have a.
Yeah, that's why I have a.
I know.
I have a.
So if I die by.
That's fine.
No, it's not fine.
I'm not going to hit her.
Oh, I used my portance.
Damn it.
I just have to.
I used them up.
That's the same thing.
My head hurts.
I can't do it right now.
I have a headache from all of it.
You all hear the music, Zane.
What to do?
Well, two minutes I guess.
No, I just want to.
That's why it's.
That's wrong ball.
That's.
That's the wrong guys.
Five.
Good night.
Yeah
And no
And this reaction
We don't ever use that
We're just trying to catch it so not throwing back
So don't use the key points
Just snack it
Just like I sort of like do a bit of lightning on my hand to like slow it down and deflect it
You don't use a key point for no if you're just trying to catch it if you throw it back you do
Is no no called Jotion
My lightning is yellow. Thank you very much
Hey
Oh
No, no wrong guy
Hey, wait a minute
Yeah
Hey, Bob
No, no, I know I'm not gonna do that. I'm not gonna do that
If he comes to me, I'm gonna operate some of the popcorn I was eating you want some?
Is he at the moment?
We're the fuck you get popcorn
I have a dash
He's my easy
I can get the fuck away if I want. How's she gonna do fly after me?
Then 19
Do hold on
Oh
Type it
EO EO type advantage
Critical damage
How far am I?
Yeah
What up
You're gonna piss her off to where she does it
Trying to overcome that mess in the upper goods
No, thank you
You
Go
See Bob, this is how you
Things you're advantage
Yeah
Forging
Oh
We flew up 15
Go
Oh
I
Have one reaction
The natural
Yeah
Yeah, I'm just yeah, I'm just pretty moving one just get rid of it all the time
No, that's riddled in the 19 because it's less
I can do that
Yeah
Or
Go
I don't take full damage
Yeah
Okay
Out
No
Let's go bird
Can you
Well, no, I don't do a lecture damage. Does it think oh well, you're gonna fuck it
No, they just do
They don't do lightning
Up great
Yeah, it cuts my
We should do lightning
In the right
It also do fires
That's a few
No, no, yes
Let's do
Yes
Normal
I'm doing
Five
Oh
And I want this is
I
Can't go off the map
Nice good
Oh
Let's do
Cool 70
What should 70 should be 60 right?
No 70 okay 70
Yeah, let's go 35 let's not go full of the map
I can't fuck up everyone
All right, that's me yeah, I don't want to do
Fuck this group
So
Yeah, that's
No, I did I rose
Yeah, but I will
Fuck your bullets I will
No, I don't know I'm just I'm not throwing back just that's right
We have the
It's experience on the less
You know
That's
You
Yeah
This is what we're like
Throw that shit right back
If I catch it
Oh, that's not much
I'm gonna load the damage
I'm not gonna read that high I can't read that high
No, it's nine
No
What type of damage is it?
Any do is absorb fire
Yeah, yes, that's correct
Yeah, definitely did right to do that
Bob, I'm gonna fuck you up
I told you I want to see what you made up
All right, let's go all out
Yeah
Yeah, I just
Like the fight of the explosion just kind of the head absorbed and reforms
Now from less moke I'm here again
Stop fucking damn it
One hits
Four
Yeah, fuck that bullet
Like before this session you would like it hasn't been any people that can use the flag medals
I was right here
You're getting my curse, bro
It was my curse to begin with
We're gonna stay on me
Hey, I have a question guys
Because I'm gonna have to like step away for a little bit because I got to run some place real quick
Can one of y'all stream and I pull it up on my phone
And then somebody's just gonna have to make the rolls for me. I'm sorry
Okay, oh perfect perfect
No, it's
Oh, let's save them
It's
Right, we'll hit
She can't do shit to him
Don't forget to flick missiles, bro. He can still pop that
Like all this shit could be for not that
Boom
Yeah
This is fucking awesome
We need to get mouth as a pistol or something he could have won this
So quickly well, I get the reason for this
Well, she can't get to me
Also true
That one hits 23
All right, I just press the wrong thing then
Yeah, go max nine
Also plus fire
No, plus the fire
It's lighting in
To hold up fire damage
Are you gonna intervene?
Baptiste?
Earth
Oh, yeah
Well, okay, then I'll just
Like move around then smack around the back of the neck
I
I worry pips quickie fall hard
Ended here right guys
No, Bob, we're all very tired
I got in there
Roma Roma is very tired
Now we short rest and I'm getting out
No, man, I need to think about you
Yeah, let's
Yep
That was fucking dope
He is gonna be
I mean it was yeah, but if I have 70 feet am I as well use it?
No, she couldn't get to me
Like I told
I mean I saw a fight with the
Roman
I
Did
You did what?
Have fun
He's the one who wanted this he's the one who wanted the fight
I told you from the beginning Bob I wanted to see what you were made of
I
Get my chance to fight you ass like we all we all give what we want
Just step in and fight in both winners. They're made into the end and they were just like is this really the crew?
And I
You're fighting the fatty last battle
What is it going to be you verse him bro?
Like first first is me as well and then is the winner
Oh, that's I will rematch
That's really gonna be a rematch is going to be the rematch
Let's see let's just test it out
Oh
I'm living
Time bro
True
What is that to sub pass
Also
I'm sorry
Oh, because
Okay, yeah, boxer gives me
Marshall improves my
I was just wondering because for monks normally deep for yeah, and at level five it's a d6
Whatever you the Marshall die is it up to by once. I'll be at a d8 at level five.
Can we convince you to do roads that's instead?
Oh
All we have to it's an easy switch all you have to do is go in and just change this that's it's
Right now
Let's go for
A D 100 off
That's
Right
So you
What the hell
Fuck off
How is that one twice
Yeah
I
Nade my rhythm I made my wizard Bob
What do you guys want to play
What do you guys want to play like
I also only be able to play with four players at the time
Right, I'll play I could play later today if you guys are down
I just got a room
I got a door
Yeah
Oh, also already didn't have the next week
Next Sunday
Yeah
Okay
Do you know who's in charge of it so I could see what month we have to
I am but no
It's me
But if you just join game game will say like hey
I don't know these months
Okay
All right, well, I'm gonna when I come back from the bank if you guys are around I'll jump in
I will just stay in cold
Are we doing a 10 hours next week
But we need to make up time
I think
Hey, I'm
I'm
Okay, see you
We had
0.11 engine speed.
3rd. She just places third. Yeah. Oh, it's for. I guess you know whoever loses that a bottom is last and then they're fighting for a second last.
So, you know, it's not like that. And then, mouth is. Or if I first and said. And first.
It would be. I may not have the fight. You never know.
But if we need to. That. Um. Chloe Daniel in. What's his base? Have any reactions to the fights.
Okay.
I did tell you that was her. That was how we're going to fight rights.
Yeah. You know, because when he had levitating him, I thought he was going to start firing spells and he made it. He has a thing has pulled it.
No.
That's why it's like I'm just going to. I'm just going to pull the fell down a bit.
My wish is the role for stats.
My wish is to level up again. Level, please. Well, I'm happy I won. Yeah, mouth.
I'm out of this kind of. Sarah good after she was like. I don't want to fly through. Yeah. And got body. That was like. All right.
Okay.
Thank you.